doing weather for sherry this morning
nate uh is it to pool day weather
well it's going to be windy all over
whether you're at the pool or not you
want to watch for stuff flying out of
your pool take a live shot now just a
couple of moments ago the sun was hiding
behind that layer of clouds but whoa it
is full on sunshine now sun officially
up for almost a half an hour the
official temperature for las vegas at
reed international is 80 degrees but we
know it's a little cooler than that
hanging on to some lower 70's right now
summerlin but all these numbers are
going to start turning around now that
the sun has popped up over the eastern
horizon wind not really a factor but we
are going to see gusts upwards of 25 30
miles an hour so whatever your outdoor
activities now would be a really good
time to get that going
no weather alerts or air quality alerts
at this time from the clark county
department of environment and
sustainability 81 is going to be the
warm spot downtown we got a bunch of 70s
here and there again the wind is going
to be picking up throughout the day
checking in on nevada and beyond after
the 90s death valley down to 89 if you
want to call it that laughlin hanging
onto 81 over the hump and prop good
morning with your 73
54 in cedar city so yesterday we made it
to 98 we're thinking that's exactly
where we're going to be again today some
neighborhoods probably will hit triple
digits but officially just shy of that
by the way the record high for today's
date was exactly a year ago we made it
to 108 that's not going to happen today
low this morning we're thinking we may
click one more degree down but you know
what we've only had two days of
measurable rain this year adding up to
less than a quarter of an inch we should
be over two inches of rain by the time
we get to june last year at this time
we've had almost an inch of rain high
clouds and wind will continue most of
the rain staying well to the pacific
northwest of us severe storms right now
approaching dallas and remember
hurricane agathy along the west coast of
mexico the remnants crossed over into
the gulf and may become the first named
storm of the atlantic season from 98
today go to 96 tomorrow back to 98 very
windy gusts to 30 miles an hour through
tomorrow night triple digits return
monday and we climb up to 106 by
thursday